hello my name is Yan Robert CEO of all
from math core together with my
colleague Patrick
Eichenberg I will be presenting houses
the Moller can be used in education
to give you a short introduction of what
we're going to talk about so lately more
and more universities and and also high
schools have been adding system order to
the licensing and the challenge is often
that teachers don't know really how to
use modeling and simulation in general
and so we started to meet one professor
of another and we started to talk to
them and say okay what what kind of
challenges do you how would your course
and often say okay we are trying to
teach complicated complicated stuff
concepts and we have to take shortcuts
because we don't have enough time to
actually demonstrate the students what
we would like to demonstrate we talk to
the students and they had a similar
experience that sometimes they kind of
left with big holes in in in the actual
pedagogical part of it because there
wasn't enough time to do it and we're
thinking in many cases probably you can
solve that by applying modeling and
simulation but the problem is that
teachers are not really used to use
modeling simulation in many courses and
they don't have that much time to
actually develop courseware new course
courseware and and you don't have time
to teach the students and use software
at your course a little bit like Paul
Abbott was talking earlier today so
what's the solution to that well our
solution was it seems to be a common
problem there should be a common recipe
we should be able to supply like a
starting point for teachers so they can
use use modeling and simulation in their
courses so what we did two of the
students were talking with a mill and an
Alexander at mainship University where
students as to different master of the
science programs in plain shape of
university and then we're having this
problem say hi we're doing a couple of
courses we're chill okay I'm not doing
exactly what we should do to learn
really learn the course and so say okay
if we if you come to us during summer as
interns a wet work together do with the
professor's can we try to find ways to
illustrate the things you have problems
with in your course in order to take you
to another level and that is basically
what we're going to try to to present
here the two things that I have worked
on and then a third course that we have
kind of worked internal with without any
contact with any of these students or
professors yes to kind of see if the
recipe works on on courses where we
don't have contact with others and and
with that I kind of leave this for for
Patrick who will present a biochem
engineering course let's do yeah that
could have been more agile here we go so
one of the professors that we talked
with was he was teaching this for three
bio engineering courses and it's really
amazing though because when the students
they get there and it's a project course
and they get to do all this kind of
cutting into research and they they work
together with you know researchers out
there who are doing actual stuff and
they get to apply the knowledge and
stuff that they are working on that they
it's really something that when they get
out of universities many go go on to
work on this so what they what they were
doing was they were recreating
reconstructing biological but in
biochemical networks so you had like
different processes some some different
processes in the human body or some
different processes maybe in bacteria or
other organisms and they tried to figure
out what was going on there but why
the problems the professor he mentioned
to us that when they got to these this
really applied this project course they
were expected to know very much they
were expected to know these theoretical
concepts about biological networks but
the students simply they hadn't acquired
that knowledge yet and so you formalize
who could some of the problems he
mentioned first was simply that the the
complexity they studied some simple
biological networks but the complexity
clay complexity of it was not sufficient
for the courses down the line and it
simply wasn't applicable at the Masters
level and since there were many students
I mean many students is that this is the
course that when they go out and work
this is the course they have learned the
most from these kinds of concepts would
need to be applicable in a work
environment also so right so we took a
long look at how the courses kind of
looked today and for this we'll use a
running example and the example we will
use is enzyme catalysis enzyme kinetics
and just to give you an idea for you I'm
realized many of you here aren't from
biochemical backgrounds just to give you
an idea why this is important enzymes in
your body facilitates very almost all
reactions I believe and without them
they would these kinds of reactions
would be possible but would take very
long time I believe I read somewhere
that one of the key ingredients of the
synthesis of hemoglobin you know the
stuff that binds oxygen when you breathe
the binds oxygen to your blood the
synthesis of hemoglobin would take about
2.3 million years if you did
have any enzymes in your body so imagine
coming out giving blood and then you
have to wait 2.3 million years before
you get any more blood that would be
that would be quite horrible yes we can
look at a schematic of how these enzyme
catalysis how this works so in the
simplest scenario you have an enzyme
which is a protein in your body which
binds to a substrate so for example you
had launched recently one of the
proteins one the enzymes in your body
binds to the proteins in in your lunch
and breaks it down into smaller
manageable more manageable components so
this is what happens here the enzyme
binds into with your food it forms a
sort of substrate enzyme complex and
then at the end releases it and this is
this curve here is the energy
expenditure and now the food could break
down on its own depending on the you
know the the environment but it would
take a very long time and we can we can
visualize this in this is a system model
ER model built using the biochem library
and this shows exactly the same thing as
the as the schematic over here you have
here you have the substrate it goes on
together with the enzymes and forms a
complex and then at the end releases the
enzyme back and forms a product and also
you have a pathway here where in which
it doesn't it just breaks down on its
own and so you might realize that how
fast things like this are happening is a
very important subject even though you
know your body strives for homeostasis
it wants to remain constant you don't
remain constant during the day you eat
stuff you exercise and so all of these
processes happens and they take some
time and the dynamics of those processes
really important and that is what you
can use systems models to understand and
you could also do like traditional
learning and how could you study this
traditionally in for example a bio
chemistry book well you could for
example you know look at all these four
substrates all components here and then
do a plot over time so you can see how
things are things changes over time well
we have we start with an initial amount
of substrate it goes down it well first
it binds with an enzyme forming a
complex and the product goes up but this
is just one slice of reality in
actuality all these different pathways
all this different substrate you know
their initial concentration varies the
catalytic activity of the enzyme enzymes
varies and this is very very important
for the body's ability to know regulate
how much sugar is in your blood - you
know regulate the enzyme activity so
these are all different parameters and
what I just showed you now was one set
of parameter and doesn't at all paint
the whole picture so how could you study
that well traditionally you could do a
do a plot you look at for example the
amount of free enzyme which is the one
here but how it would look if the
parameters were at different well is
this the parameter cake at is the is the
reaction rate happening yeah but what is
lacking from this you know this learning
that they are having today is well the
professor it felt like you know they
aren't quite getting the intuition from
these kinds of graphs here they aren't
quite getting the intuition that they
need to
understand the dynamics and you know
this is this example it's just one very
simple example so it was just force
substrate that is not how it looks in
your body and these are the kinds of
things we are teaching to our students
traditionally but and they are expected
to infer kind of a network behavior just
from those simple components and that
it's not at all how it works when you
connect it all together
so our how do do did we want to tackle
this problem because you know we really
good contact with its professor so we
sat down thought okay how are we gonna
you know what can we do about this so we
had one summer intern here
millarca stalled during the summer and
we gave him two days system model and
Mathematica crash course and asked him
to you know narrow that with this
traditional learning narrowed down what
is it that is missing so we so he you
know he was thinking about okay so I and
he has taken these courses so he was
thinking about all right how would I
have liked to learn these concepts and
he came up with an implementation that
where he created student assignments
that they were allowed to you know they
got a problem and they were supposed to
solve it using Mathematica and system
ogler and also implemented demonstration
for how this could be applied in a
biochemical in a biochemical network in
logic biochemical pathways so let's look
at one listen and in fact the running
example I've used is one of is from one
of his assignments which deals with
enzyme reactions so this was one of the
the ones I actually almost have prayed
for this one of the models he built
where we study the reaction rate of an
enzyme and you know what what this
having this model it allows allowed the
student to look at different the
different parts of the process and for
themselves set different very different
values to this parameter so I mean I
mean I could I could for example look at
all right what happens if I change the
k-kat parameter to one or two two and
two three or four and right now we were
looking at the free enzyme we could also
look at the product formation the
product formation you know so the
students can use this and try for
themselves to see how how the system
responds to them but it's just not it's
not just as static in static static
image in a in a textbook anymore it's
something that they can interact with
and in fact when we're talking about
interaction he went and took this one
step further where he implemented we
implemented interactive interactive
manipulates where you can could drag in
different sliders like this so here we
have four different parameters affecting
in this simple this simple system we
have the binding rate between the
substrate and the enzyme we have the
reverse sometimes the complex just lets
loose without without it going further
and forming a product and the cake at
and the other one down here so they
could manipulate this these for
themselves and directly see directly see
how these parameter values affect this
model that I've just shown and we
believe this is something that will give
Kahneman in the intuition to the
students to how these how these systems
work and these are just some of the
parameters we could include for example
the starting value of the enzyme the
starting value of the substrate in we
and this is then used to you know answer
specific questions about the system so
if you
all right you have zero binding binding
rate to the enzyme and the this this
reaction here it doesn't happen then
you'll see that you that is one of the
questions and then you see the oh well
these parameters they don't affect the
system in any way but this one the the
non-catholic digression the one there it
just breaks down spontaneously that
effects a system so this is kind of the
intuition you can get from this and so
this was dealing with Kannon the
knowledge of the system dynamics now we
still haven't talked about larger
networks but nice thing here is that
while we're doing this and this is a
this is a model here that you might you
know a professor might give this to a
student that it's pre-built the students
don't have to do anything they can just
play around with it but now they have
this model they've familiarized
themselves with its model and then they
can do all these nice things so instead
of you know building this from scratch
and see seeing how everything works they
can take this and you know do slight C
in this system on oh by the way I don't
think we've shown this yes all right for
you don't aren't familiar this is system
aller so this is where the model was
created so they can do all these like
modifications and get a better
understanding so like if I change this
to to an ambient substance here what
happens now is that after the enzyme is
often enzyme has reacted the it goes
away it doesn't exist anymore this could
for example signify that the enzyme
would break down after the reaction
selves very bad so hopefully doesn't do
that but they can do this they
familiarize themselves with the modeling
they could do this these kind of
modifications for themselves and see how
it affects the system so now
now the substrate and the enzyme mixture
has the same concentration because they
start the same and when it when the
substrate they're pleased so does the
enzymes and you know what is nice is you
can go back to the Monday manipulate we
had here and reevaluate
still use these kind of pre-built
control object and suddenly we're no
longer looking at the professor's model
we're looking at oh right I think that I
might use the wrong one
okay but inside we're no longer looking
at the professor's model we're looking
at the ones the students they modify
them these themselves they they are the
office of the model and in fact we can
this can be one of the course where's
that EML developed was something where
you know it was this is in principle the
same as the enzyme model that we've
looked at previously we have the complex
here in the middle but instead we have
we have two substrates we have one
enzyme that can go to different
confirmations and we have two products
and stuff like that and it's just a it's
a bigger modification of the model and
instead of just having the small small
components and inferred network
structure they can actually start and
build up that networks structure from
the small components and the verdict
tables that they were very very
impressed and want to implement this in
the biochemistry course that's due this
spring I think and also in fact the the
larger model that I showed here they
want to use that in a in a higher
education biochemistry course where they
do more kind of Applied Research
and of course a very important part also
is the thing that the that is to interns
we have here that they learned they felt
that they got a lot from you know
modifying this and they learned things
about the sabe there were fourth year
through third year students maybe and
that had gone through these courses but
they learned so much more by you know
being able to manipulate and build these
structures for themselves and just
reaching in
[Music]
I have none are you having okay so this
should come up soon I hope it is let's
try my adapter oh that's the only one
let's try this
yep okay so that was a biochemistry
course then we looked at it something
that should be kind of completely
different and what we chose was a cdio
project course where the students were
supposed to develop a sunlight this
simulator so the course that course was
also from in Chapman University we're
based in lean shipping so it's just next
door to us so it's kind of easy for us
to interact with them and the goal from
this course was to develop this sunlight
simulator for students in a way so so
the researchers later on could be able
could could use that in their research
with small modifications so it's a
pretty high level of the main goal here
the students were second grade so they
didn't have that much theory of
theoretical concepts in their bag so to
speak when they came to the course and
the setup or the course is that they
have to have these LED matrices 8x8 8
LED matrices that will that they will
try to control in order to to simulate
the sunlight then they have da cue cards
LabVIEW measurement equipment and so on
and the setup is something like this
with well you will actually understand
some of the Swedish word like positive
Lin's you can understand that right but
basically this is a setup that are
trying to construct and and in order to
do that what we do is basically the
first start by designing the different
parts so for instance designing the
electrical circuit we look at that part
how do they do to design the the
amplifier system for for each channel of
the LED matrix well the students started
by doing their join their analog circuit
and look something like this then they
went to the professor or the assistant
showed it to the assistants I said okay
look does this look good
and I said I'm great
perfect you're then exactly what you
should however he says and it's perhaps
a little bit small
let's see however it says the world is
not ideal and you have worked with ideal
components so he takes their their
suggested circuit and says you should
add this capacitor here now the
capacitor here that capacitor should
have this value and that's one should
have this value now start implementing
them okay
they did that but of course they will
left a little bit cumbersome the problem
was the student didn't really understand
there was something with non idea of
world that they had to take some kind of
account for but there was the assistant
doing that for them and this was a
frustration for assistant and it was the
frustration for a student so well why
are you doing it this way well because
the tools he has were using SPICE are
too advanced in order to show the
non-ideal effects it costs too much
there's no time to do that so he said
okay I don't see any solution to that
problem so they will were basically left
without really feeling that they
understood this step which was very
important so even if they succeeded with
the project later on they did that with
an animal feeling that we cheated we
didn't get it entirely so one of the
students Alexander Nass yesterday with
Emil we gave him a two-day system Orion
Mathematica crash course had never used
any of the software's before and then we
started to discuss a little bit how
non-ideal effects could be illustrated
with him and with their professors for a
couple of days and then it was up to him
to see if he could resolve the problem
so what he did was a few demonstrations
or manipulates that he basically took
teach himself but since that thing can
be applied for students so let's look at
those
for one of the things he did so he has
this this is basically a very small
version of what they were supposed to do
so this is how the student solution is
looked at because now we have ideal
components here everything is working
perfectly fine as it should and his
first assignment to the students is
listen I should have this small
manipulate where you can see that how
does this kind of OPM plafond marry at
all if we that we here understand a
no-parent of her or not but basically
you know ideal op-amp amplifier will
take if you have the the right-hand
resistor a 100k ohms divided that with
the left hand ten then you have the
magnification but this is also in
inverting so it will be negative 10 so
if they did he basically made an
application is more manipulate where
they can change the resistance and see
how it changes kind of boring but this
was basically the level understanding
they had in the course when they
designed designed their analog circuit
so next thing you did is so let's add
let's switch this to a non-ideal opie
amplifier instead so the circuit
basically looks the same the open
amplifier has a little bit more details
inside it and then let's look at how
that would kind of behave so suddenly
here we see there's some kind of
overshoot it's the very same short
circuit but there's overshoot and now if
they start changing here we'll see okay
that chance of their increase this I'll
have that effect and so on so suddenly
here is he okay the world if they made
the same here in their ideal world it
would look perfectly I can go back and
say like 55 mm and 35 can go up here
choose something similar
55:35 doesn't marry please exactly same
this is how they believe it worked
previously but by saving here with this
small circuit and they can play around
and say okay this is the type of effects
are actually get from a circuit some of
the get an understanding or why they
need these capacitors so next step with
us with this one is that he he adds
corrective filters and the difference
here is he has added this capacitor here
and this one here otherwise it's the
very same circuit as the previous one
and now with us corrected and this was
what the gut from the from the from
their assistance before that was are the
capacitors basically got just like the
larger circuit but they got those and
then they this was is the kind of
response you get done with damp so we
don't have the overshoot it looks nicer
and we can start to kind of play around
with these guys here and see how it
works so we see that this capacitor
actually have an interesting effect so
what's the next step well the the
assistant of course he gave him the
values of the capacitors also so why not
allow them to actually manipulate the
capacitance of each capacitor like
increase this one decrease that one and
see how these actual values affect the
circuit so with these small apps that
the professor or in this case when our
student has developed he can supply that
to the other students of the course in
the future and they will be able to play
around and actually realize why are
these capacitors needed and even by
themselves choose the right capacitors
rather than and having the assistant
giving it to them so it's pretty nice so
with that said and then I will go
quickly he F afterwards she started to
do so all this is fun so can we do a
little bit more so we're starting to do
other like longer assignments with with
a introduction some questions
a little bit more and programming and so
on and we believe this is kind of what
will happen once you start to actually
sorry see there the fun of it a few
students will want to do this extra and
the professor of also all then I walk to
T I want to teach this and teach
laterals or so also adding those two
other courses
so basically yet again the professor the
assistant and the students were very
happy with what they got from an intern
project and so then okay if from two
courses that where I work together with
with students and professors it turns
out that it was pretty easy for for the
students to actually reach another level
for the course now the professors are
not still they're good professors but
still a student could with some
assistance in some discussions with us
on the professor add value to the course
in such a short time it's pretty nice so
suppose that we were trying to do that
on a course that is we're not involved
in so we looked at the MIT
OpenCourseWare selected the mechanical
engineering dynamics course and took a
look at that and now Internet is
probably not working so I'll go this so
this is basically how how MIT
open-source course will looks like there
tons of courses they will have some
description of the course and in a bunch
of different material like quizzes and
so on they will also have so in this
particular case the course is taught in
our undergraduate level in mechanical
engineering and they have the goals of
learning a few different concepts okay
so let's take a look at that so how do
they do that well what they do is they
they get textbook for some reason that
opens up a little bit down here the
basic get this PDF where the doesn't
want to assume for some reason can I
assume here instead
[Music]
okay there you go okay so basically it's
a bunch of text some figures showing a
different mechanical hairs a beam with a
spring and position somewhere and then
equations more takes more equations so
this is basically what they are learning
which is of course that that's what
they're supposed to learn but note
there's not one single illustration of
what's actually going on if we look at
one of the those exercises you get is
within lagrange equations so basically
the mechanics are that you can either
teach through classical mechanics which
in sweden we all almost only teach
classical mechanics or you can use like
a Lagrange equations in France they
almost only use of like Raj equations
and then in some countries like in the
u.s. you use both depending on professor
and so on but anyway so this the in this
course they're using like Lagrange
equations and they get different
problems like this to resolve before and
they are basically supposed to solve
these equations and set up the system of
equations for solving Lagrange equations
their solutions will look let's keep
that their solutions will will look
something like this we're looking at a
spring for instance will be similarly
this from the book it will be these
equations in our perspective we work
with equations all day is this is fine
this is great this is of course what
describes the problem but how many here
actually could tell me how this system
behaves from those equations directly
it's a very simple system spring-mass
how does it behave do we think that the
students will understand this most of
them will not I'm pretty sure you could
use Mathematica of course to solve
equations these equations and get some
plots and so on I will not be doing this
here for the sake of time but you can
also model the thing in system modeler
so if we let me just close this so we
see them together if you see this we
have the the spring and a mass and this
is basically the same that we have
modeled in system model so if I take
this model now and let's yeah let's open
it in simulation center so now we will
simulate this in simulation center and
it will give us an automatic plot of the
position of the pendulum how many saw
that but from the equations hand up
problem none it's kind of difficult to
understand right but now you can get
this and why does it look like this well
we can in this case this is the system
with a spring we have a very weak spring
and of course depending on the frequency
here and and and the spring constant now
this spring spring has actually there's
a spring in in both x and y direction so
it can twist in both and depending on
what you set values here you will get
different behaviors so now you can test
your equations and see what will happen
and we'll think this like just giving
the this model so they can relate the
equations to some reality will help them
quite a lot
okay so in the same whether we think
that once they have actually been able
to soul something like this and and he
did and we did several different similar
material for them perhaps they would
like to do more advanced stuff perhaps a
few of them would say oh okay there was
fun let me do two more stuff so we
created some more advanced assignments
and for instance here we will we will
have an assignment with a double
pendulum mister there's no Springs
involved in this case and we'll give the
students questions of different types
like the same type of questions that you
actually get in the current course we
also have the solutions here so they're
actually supposed to solve these
equations yes they're doing today but
we're also supplying them with the
models so they can try out this an
experiment with it and then we gave okay
once you can if you won't want now now
when you understood this model if you
want to do something more advanced
because when you're doing around more
advanced you will not be able to do that
by hand any longer now let's start doing
a little bit of fun stuff here let's do
life a little bit more complicated get
this one try to see how that works
perhaps develop a swing choir song so
let's look at how that looks like we're
gonna simulate the model of this one is
it see here if I can find it
pendulum will swing Oh this rotating
swing sorry okay so basically this all
the things you see on the right hand
side there is different it's it's
separate swing and each of those
separate swings is very much the same
kind of pendulum model that they have
older model so just using again and
again and putting it on a plate and you
can either of course supply this to the
students so they get the whole solution
and yes can experiment just to see give
it some more like flesh and blood they
can probably remember when they were
playing in the swing I prepare this
beforehand because it kind of takes I
think one and a half minute or something
like that to simulate so and even if you
actually have some extra time it will be
quite boring two minutes to wait so I
prepare that then so let's look at it
here it is so here is what the model
shows and it will start rotating after a
while very pretty slow we are kind to
our users in the beginning after a while
probably if you're on it and and you
will kind of feel some a little bit of
trickle in your stomach or something
like that because after a while this
will kind of spin and look and then of
course you can give them plots and show
different forces and suddenly this like
ranch equation that AHA has come alive
with some small steps and they really
for for a professor to develop this
material that we develop for most
professor one time that time so of
course but if they if they had this
material or had something to start with
they could do quite amazing stuff so
that comes to there oh this was the one
notebook
that's one oh sorry
someday I will get learning to how to
use use Mac a Mac so what we did is we
started with these and a couple of other
courses our idea is to start to actually
make a bunch of different materials that
we will provide over the web and where
do we think that that this will be able
upon in a bunch of courses any course
where you can use system owner of course
you could do this it could be social
science or it could be chemistry or
aerospace it's not limited biochemical
engineering mechanical engineering
Electrical Engineering those three are
pretty far away from each other still we
could do pretty nice stuff that we think
adds a lot of value to the students so
anyone that has an idea for a course
that you would like us to help with we
are happy to talk to you what we'll do
then is kind of two similar things to
here and make it available online in
order to have a slightly better make it
available online so other professors can
download it get inspiration and use that
in their courses
so with that I'll thanks and questions
[Applause]